Wikipedia. Wikipedia. One of the central organizing principles of Wikipedia in the tech world, I think it's kind of, people sort of laugh at me, but we talk about love. Hey look, I'm a Catholic priest. Imposs.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 43 und bevor ich sie wieder vergesse, sag ich gleich mal, wer am Mikrofon ist, nämlich Tim Pritlove ist mein Name und heute geht es um ein Thema, was wir schon mal beim Chaosradio hatten und zwar die Wikipedia und da wir das beim Chaosradio auch schon mal hatten, soll es diesmal um die etwas fortgeschrittenen Konzepte gehen. Wir machen mal einen Rückblick, wie Wikipedia sich so entwickelt hat und was die Aufgaben sind, die sich heute stellen. Denn Wikipedia ist mittlerweile kein Projekt mehr, was man der Welt mal mitteilen muss, dass es das gibt. Es ist ein reißender Erfolg geworden und ist natürlich auch in der letzten Zeit zunehmend in die Kritik gekommen. Ich habe auch wieder ein Gast dabei, wie sollte es auch anders sein. Es ist auch jemand, der vor kurzem schon mal da war, hatten schon darüber gesprochen. Ich begrüße Maha. Hallo Maha. Vielleicht sollte ich erst mal dein Mikrofon einschalten. Jetzt darfst du es nochmal probieren. Es funktioniert immer noch nicht. Aber jetzt? Jetzt ist ja auch gleich wieder alles ein bisschen chaotisch. Denn wir testen endlich nach Monaten ein neues Mikrofon-Setup. Genaugenommen ist es ja deins. Das ist das, was ich schon immer haben wollte. Ich will das auch haben, das ist toll. Also super Klangqualität, super geile Headsets hier von Bayer Dynamik, ganz großartig.
Sieht auch gut aus. Also es muss irgendwann mal ein Video-Podcast kommen. Also Tim mit diesem samstgeschwungenen Mikrofonballen.
Das ist aber auch super ausmachtlich. Gut, kommen wir zum tierischen Ernst. Der tierische Ernst heißt Wikipedia und Wikipedia für Fortgeschrittene. Was ist los mit dem Projekt? Vielleicht erst noch mal den Grund, warum ich das jetzt mit dir mache. Wir hatten ja uns vor zwei Sendungen sehr ausführlich über Sprachen unterhalten. Auch ein sehr interessanter Podcast in deiner Eigenschaft sozusagen als Linguist und als Professor für, wie heißt das offiziell?
Romanische Sprachwissenschaft.
Romanische Sprachwissenschaft. Aber du hast ja noch einen anderen Hut auf. Ich habe gesehen davon, dass du natürlich auch CCC-Mitglied bist hier in Berlin. Bist du auch in der Wikipedia aktiv und das auch schon ziemlich lange, oder?
Seit Anfang 2003. Also da ging es eigentlich so richtig los mit der deutschen Wikipedia. Also ich hatte das Gefühl damals, dass das noch ein Embryo war, gerade im Vergleich zu heute. Wir waren damals, wir machten da irgendwie eine Party bei jedem zehntausendsten Artikel, der neu war und freuten uns für den nächsten Stammtisch, dann endlich 50.000 und so und jetzt, also man kommt gar nicht nach, ich wollte noch so sagen, ja jetzt haben wir die 500.000 überschritten und wenn ich jetzt gerade hier drauf gucke, sind es in der deutschen Wikipedia, müssen wir gleich schon uns vorbereiten auf die 600.000, also es geht wirklich rasend schnell und das war damals nicht abzusehen, dass das so schnell geht. Also wir haben jetzt 1,6 Millionen in der englischen Wikipedia, das habe ich jetzt auch nicht nachkontrolliert, aber ich denke mal, wir sind da noch ja fast 1,7 und 560.000 in der…
Ich glaube, du musst mal dein Telefon ausschalten, das interferiert. Das interferiert auch, wenn es…
Das ist erschrecklich.
Ja, ja, das sind digitale, du weißt schon, Pakete und so.
Ja, genau, genau.
Sollte mal einer, man könnte das nicht abhören. Ja, an die Zeit kann ich mich auch noch… schmeiß es doch einfach in den See.
Jetzt ist es aus, jetzt ist es wirklich aus.
Es spielt aber noch Bildschirminformation ab.
Ja, ja, ich schmeiß es doch…
Oder fällt mir ein, meinst du es auch noch an? Oh Gott, wir erreichen hier nicht den gebotenen tierischen Ernst. Also, bleiben wir noch mal einen Moment bei der Euphorie. Ich kann mich auch noch sehr gut erinnern. Die Zeit, von der du gesprochen hast, da war einfach alles davon bestimmt, dass man da jetzt was gefunden hat, was einfach ein Tor öffnet, das Weltwissen das erste Mal effektiv zu sammeln. Und in dem Hinblick muss man auch sagen, das Projekt ist auch einfach gelungen. Also es ist einfach gelungen, unglaubliche Mengen an Menschen zu motivieren, in einem einheitlichen System Inhalt beizutragen. Und wir werden jetzt auch noch ausführlich darüber reden, wo da die Schwierigkeiten sind, die sich aufgetan haben. Aber zu Beginn waren natürlich die Schwierigkeiten erst mal gar kein Thema. Also es war einfach erst mal klar, der gordische Knoten war gelöst worden. Man hatte das Werkzeug gefunden, mit dem es einfach möglich ist. Das ist das Wiki, was ja mittlerweile auch seinen Weg macht in viele andere Sachen. Also das Media-Wiki, die Software von der Wikipedia, wird ja beileibe nicht nur für Wikipedia eingesetzt, sondern es ist einfach mittlerweile der Goldstandard für Wikisysteme. Nicht, dass es da noch eine ganze Menge... Ich glaube, das hat noch einen sehr, sehr, sehr langen Weg vor sich, was nicht heißen soll, dass es für das ungeeignet ist, wofür es geschrieben ist. Also für die Wikipedia als Kernanwendung ist es einfach super. Für andere Anwendungen wird man sehen, das wird sich dann noch einiges tun. Aber auch derzeit ist ja auch die Entwicklung stark. Aber bevor wir auf die Wikipedia kommen, vielleicht mal noch so ein paar Schritte, was seitdem geschehen ist. Also wir waren jetzt so bei 2003, es ging los, es wird groß gejubelt. Was würdest du sagen, waren denn dann so die wichtigsten Schritte, die danach genommen wurden?
Das hängt natürlich so ein bisschen von der Perspektive ab. Also ich habe natürlich jetzt vor allem so die deutsche Perspektive vor Augen. Und da war es natürlich dann, dass hier der Verein gegründet worden ist, also Wikimedia Deutschland. Und das war ja auch zunächst mal so ein ganz kleiner Verein, wo sich ein paar Leute damals in der TU bei der vorletzten Wizard of Oz getroffen haben. Das war, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, 2004. Und dann hat sich das auch entwickelt. Und inzwischen gibt es eben ja sogar eine Geschäftsstelle mit einem hauptamtlichen Mitarbeiter. Und wenn man da auch den Grad der Professionalisierung anschaut, ist das schon in kürzester Zeit geschehen. Und setzt das Ganze natürlich auch auf eine viel breitere Ebene. Weil man wäre um diese Schritte ja auch nie herumgekommen, weil es inzwischen ja so ist, dass täglich so und so viele Anfragen kommen von Journalisten. Das kann man einfach auf so einer ehrenamtlichen Schiene gar nicht mehr bearbeiten in Deutschland.
Das heißt, es gibt ein Wikimedia e.V., der heißt explizit nicht Wikipedia e.V., Ich meine, nimmt er überhaupt irgendeine Rechtsposition ein, die jetzt wirklich was mit der Wikipedia zu tun hat?
Na, es ist ja ein Förderverein zunächst mal. Da wollten Leute sich einfach zusammentun, um ihn besser spenden zu können. Also wirklich der Grund für diese Gründung war zunächst mal so was wie Spenden sammeln. Also gut, da ist es natürlich ein bisschen weitergegangen. Nämlich auch eine Infrastruktur zu schaffen, um die Deutsche Wikipedia, wo man also Presseanfragen beantworten kann und eben auch als Organisationsform für die Beantwortung von Anfragen mit so einem Ticketsystem. Das muss ja alles irgendwie organisiert werden. Und das übernimmt eben dieser Verein.
Der jetzt auch ein Büro hat?
Der jetzt ein Büro in Frankfurt hat, genau. Und das ist eben nicht nur einfach ein Förderverein, sondern eben auch ein Rahmen, um eben die Bedürfnisse der Wikipedianutzer auch zu erfüllen.
Und das geschieht? Was sind denn die Bedürfnisse der Wikipedianutzer?
Ja, da kommen halt täglich irgendwelche Anfragen rein von Leuten, die halt irgendwo ein Problem sehen und da eben eine Beantwortung brauchen. Da gibt es also sehr viele Fragen in Bezug auf das Urheberrecht. Also man muss auch irgendwie klären, wenn da jemand ein Bild zur Verfügung stellt, dann muss er ja irgendjemandem gegenüber auch mal klar machen, dass er da eine Lizenz hat und so. Da muss es Leute geben, die sich darum kümmern. Und das wird eben dann auch koordiniert. Durch Freiwillige natürlich. Also der Verein hat zwar einen hauptamtlichen Geschäftsführer, aber die Hauptlast der Arbeit wird natürlich nach wie vor durch Freiwillige gemacht. Aber das muss eben auch organisiert werden. Da kann man nicht einfach nur sagen, ja, das machen wir jetzt irgendwie im Netz. Sondern da muss es Leute geben, die sich darum kümmern, die das sammeln, die halt so einen Server betreiben, wo man halt so Ticketsachen machen, also bearbeiten kann, also Anfragen und so. Und da muss es eben eine Infrastruktur dafür geben. Und das übernimmt eben der Verein.
Und davon abgesehen, was sind so die anderen wichtigen Schritte gewesen, die danach stattfanden?
Na, es hat sich auch schon eine ganze Menge getan. Also ein ganz wichtiger Bereich Forschung über die Wikipedia. Da hat es ja nun bereits auch abgeschlossene Forschungsprojekte gegeben. Es gibt auch ja Veröffentlichungen inzwischen. Und es gibt laufend neue Forschungsprojekte, die zum Teil eben auch durch Forschungsinstitutionen, wie die Deutsche Forschungsgemeinschaft, unterstützt werden. Also wir haben ja im letzten Jahr auch wieder auf der Visit auf Oz ein Symposium gemacht über Wikipedia-Forschung. Und da wurden zehn Forschungsprojekte vorgestellt. Und das ist natürlich auch nur die Spitze des Eisbergs.
Was sind das so für Produkte?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also es gibt einen ganz breiten Bereich aus einerseits der Soziologie, wo man also erforschen will, wer sind die Leute, die da die Wikipedia benutzen? Wie funktioniert das eben als gesellschaftliches Phänomen oder als Gruppenphänomen? Auch die Frage der Zusammenarbeit ist da wichtig. Und das Ganze kann man jetzt auch nochmal aus einer psychologischen Perspektive betrachten. Da gibt es also Leute, Kommunikationswissenschaftler und Organisationspsychologen, die sich eben anschauen, wie eben da auch Zusammenarbeit funktioniert. Das ist die eine Schiene. Und die andere Schiene beschäftigt sich mehr mit den Inhalten und was man alles mit den Inhalten machen kann. Also ein ganz großer Bereich, die KI-Forschung, also künstliche Intelligenz. Da gibt es so Ansätze mit dem sogenannten Semantic Web. Also wie wird Wissen organisiert? Was kann man mit Begriffen anfangen? Welche Begriffe hängen wie zusammen? Ja, und das wird eben auch erforscht, um dann eben auch vielleicht Nutzen daraus zu ziehen. Also Anwendungen sind ja vielfältig.
Absolut, also ich meine mit dem Datenbestand, aber dann auch mit dieser sozialen Dynamik, da sehe ich auch noch eine ganze Menge Beschäftigungspotenziale.
Also einmal Ausweitung des Datenbestands, das ist eben die eine Schiene, und das andere eben zu beobachten, wie die Leute zusammenarbeiten. Ja, und da gibt es inzwischen ja nun auch schon einige interessante Erkenntnisse. Ein Klassiker ist diese Geschichte mit dem History Flow. Das kommt nun nicht aus Deutschland. Diese zehn Forschungsprojekte beziehen sich allein auf die deutsche Forschungslandschaft. Aber international passiert natürlich noch viel mehr. Also History Flow ist so ein Konzept, mit dem man beobachten kann, wie sich Wikipedia-Artikel verändern.
Da gab es ja schon vor x Jahren schon mal diese Untersuchungen von IBM, oder?
IBM, das ist diese ganz klassische Untersuchung. Aber vor zig Jahren zig nicht, also 2003.
Na ja, ein Jahr sind zehn Internetjahre, kommen mir immer vor wie zehn Jahre, weil sich einfach immer so dermaßen viel tut und ändert. Das heißt, dieses Projekt gibt es noch, also genau dieses eine Projekt gibt es noch bei IBM. Die machen da weiter dran.
So viel ich weiß, machen die weiter.
Okay, weil ich hatte das damals wahrgenommen als, naja, wir haben da mal so mal reingeguckt und hier und guck mal, ist schön bunt, hat mich auch gewundert, warum das da nicht fortgeführt wurde. Aber vielleicht wurde es auch fortgeführt und ich habe einfach...
Na ja, also eins der deutschen Projekte von der Deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft hat das auch aufgegriffen. Die gucken halt besonders, wie kollaboratives Arbeiten aus kommunikationswissenschaftlicher Perspektive aussieht. Die wollen auch vergleichen, was passiert bei Wikis in Betrieben mit dem, was in der Wikipedia passiert. Also eingeschränkte Öffentlichkeit, große Öffentlichkeit. Und die nutzen, also entwickeln auch dieses Konzept des History Flows weiter. Das ist eine ganz wichtige Grundlage für deren Forschung. Und ja, also was da rausgekommen ist, das Projekt ist gerade angelaufen. Ende 2006, also genaueres weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, finde ich super spannend. Vielleicht sollte man nochmal kurz erwähnen, History Flow. Also ich habe noch diese Grafiken im Blick, wo man im Prinzip die gesamte Entstehung des Artikels sieht, so von links nach rechts über die Zeit abgetragen. Der wird dann immer länger, also so von oben nach unten. Und farblich kann man dann aber erkennen, welche Textblöcke sozusagen aus welchen Versionen es geschafft haben. Also wenn eine Textstelle beibehalten bleibt über einen längeren Zeitraum, dann ist das halt ein sich so fortsetzendes farbiges Band.
Genau.
In dem Moment, wo eine neue Änderung einschlägt und das ersetzt, ist das Band halt an der Stelle zu Ende, sodass man eben auch bewerten kann, oh, dieser Text steht nicht nur in diesem Artikel, sondern der steht da schon verdammt lange. Was natürlich auch eine Aussage darüber macht. Und eigentlich wäre es ganz schick, wenn man diesen History-Flow auch in der Software hätte, dass ich sagen kann, jetzt gucke ich mir mal diesen Artikel an, nicht schwarz auf weiß, sondern irgendwie bunt auf weiß, um einfach zu sehen, ah, hier, das ist jetzt irgendwie schön eingebrannt, das hat schon Farbe. Gibt es das schon?
Da ist auch einiges gemacht, das wäre der nächste Punkt, den ich angesprochen hätte, in der Rubrik, was bisher geschah. Der Deutsche Verein hat eben einen Tool-Server eingerichtet, also einen Server, der sich nur mit der Auswertung der Wikipedia beschäftigt. Vorher ist das ja auf der Original-Datenbank gemacht worden, und das frisst natürlich unheimliche Ressourcen, wenn da jemand hergeht und einfach jetzt mal so eine gigantische Auswertung durchführt. Und das ist ausgelagert worden auf einen speziellen Server, der wird aber auch regelmäßig abgedatet. Das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich, aber man kann vielleicht so sagen, alle paar Stunden gibt es da wieder eine neue, aktualisierte Wikipedia. Und jedenfalls ist das das Ziel. Das läuft im Augenblick vielleicht noch nicht so richtig. Und dann kann man halt auf der Basis dieser Datenbank sich genau angucken, was da alles geschieht. Und da gibt es wunderschöne Seiten. Also unter dem Stichwort Statistik kann man da eine Menge sich anschauen.
Das heißt, diese Server, die werden dann auch von Wikimedia e.V.
betrieben? Genau.
Und da fließen dann auch die Spenden mit rein?
Da fließen die Spenden mit rein. Wir hatten halt das Problem, das ist halt die Frage des deutschen Steuerrechts. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach Geld in die USA überweisen. Und viele haben halt gesagt, wir wollen spenden für Server. Wir wollen einfach, dass die Sache besser wird und Server haben.
Dann geht das nämlich nicht.
Das geht nicht, ohne weiteres.
Dann sollten wir kurz die Sachen mit der Foundation aufklären.
Genau, der eigentliche Betreiber der Wikipedia ist die Wikipedia Foundation in Florida.
In diesem Fall Pedia, nicht Media. Also Wikipedia Foundation heißt sie, nicht Wikimedia Foundation. Ist auch Wikimedia Foundation.
Weil sie ja nicht nur die Wikipedia betreut, sondern auch die anderen Schwester von nicht.
Okay, ich dachte du hast gerade Pedia gesagt. Nur das wird da ganz klar sein.
Das ist also international der Träger der Wikipedia und der Schwester, der Schwesterprojekte. Und natürlich ist der Deutsche Verein zwar unabhängig und auch unabhängig gegründet worden, aber versteht sich natürlich auch als Local Chapter, also als Landesverband der Wikimedia Foundation. Obwohl die Wikimedia Foundation, wie der Name schon sagt, eine Stiftung ist also kein Mitgliederverein. Da kann man nicht Mitglied werden, sondern da gibt es halt nur die Stiftung eben mit einem Leitungsgremium und die kümmern sich halt dann um, die sind letztlich auch die Verantwortlichen für den Betrieb der Server und natürlich irgendwie auch die letztlich Verantwortlichen für die Inhalte. Also wenn man jemanden juristisch belangen will, dann eben die Wikimedia Foundation.
Und die, ja, und der Wikimedia e.V. ist davon komplett unabhängig?
Ist an sich unabhängig, versteht sich aber wie gesagt als Landesverband, also sozusagen als derjenige, der sich hier in Deutschland um das Drumherum und auch um das Spenden sammeln kümmert. Und die Wikimedia Foundation international sammelt also jetzt nicht parallel zu Wikimedia Deutschland Spenden in Deutschland, sondern das macht eben Wikimedia Deutschland. Und da ergibt sich eben das Problem, natürlich gibt es viele Leute, die in Deutschland dann spenden wollen für die Server, aber man kann jetzt nicht einfach mit dem deutschen Steuerrecht so umgehen, dass man so, aha, wer soll mal ein Geld einschicken, das sind die USA. Dann entzieht es sich auch letztlich der Prüfbarkeit, ob das alles richtig verwendet wird und deshalb muss das eben auch hier verwendet werden. Und auf diese Weise, man hat dann den Kompromiss gefunden, dass man eben spezielle Server einschafft, die dann eben teil auf…
Weil die anderen Dienste machen, die die anderen nicht machen.
Genau, und das ist eben genau dieser Tool-Server, in der da ein Vorhang besteht.
Aber wenn dieser Spendenaufruf in der Wikipedia selbst eingeblendet ist, das war ja jetzt schon zwei, drei Mal der Fall, das ist dann schon eine Aktion in den USA. Da geht es um die eigentlichen Grenzen.
Ja, aber wenn man dann da draufklickt, dann steht da eben auch, sie können in Deutschland spenden auf das deutsche Konto. Kann natürlich mit PayPal überall hinbezahlen und auch in die USA oder mit der Kreditkarte.
Dann hat man sozusagen die Wahl.
Aber man kann eben auch nach Deutschland spenden, hat den Vorteil, dass man da seine Spendenbescheinigung bekommt, dass man das steuerlich geltend machen kann. Und dass man vielleicht auch, wenn man dann Mitglied im Verein ist, auch die Arbeit des deutschen Vorstands gut kontrollieren kann und dann auch Nein sagen kann, wenn einem was nicht passt. Das kann man bei der Wikimedia Foundation international nicht ganz so gut, weil es da keine Mitgliedsstruktur gibt.
Wie viele Mitglieder hat ja Wikimedia e.V. mittlerweile gewonnen?
Ein paar Hundert, aber das müsste ich jetzt nochmal nachschauen.
Okay, aber es ist nicht so, dass jetzt jeder gleich Mitglied wird.
Nein, also vergleichsweise wenig. Wenn man halt sieht, wie viele Tausende da letztlich mitarbeiten und auch registriert sind, ist das natürlich vergleichsweise wenig.
Okay, kommen wir vielleicht mal weg von dieser ganzen bürokratischen Überbaustruktur und gehen auch mal so ein bisschen mehr auf die Probleme oder die Herausforderungen, die die Wikimedia selbst jetzt so hat. Nachdem so die erste große Euphorie verflogen war und man dann auch jetzt nicht mehr nochmal mitjubeln musste, dass es eine Online-Institut, die es im Internet gibt, wo alle mitschreiben können, dann gab es erstmal so eine Phase der Beruhigung, dann passiert erstmal eine ganze Wahl am Nichts. Und es wuchs halt einfach nur so das Projekt.
Es gab plötzlich Schwesterprojekte und so, da tat sich die ganze Menge.
Ich spreche jetzt nur für eine öffentliche Wahrnehmung. Aber kannst du da ruhig mal eingreifen? Die Schwesterprojekte?
Genau. Vor allen Dingen denke ich als wichtigstes Schwesterprojekt Commons, wo halt multimediale Inhalte bereitgestellt werden. Und das ist natürlich auch nochmal eine Sache, die ganz interessant geworden ist, weil man da jetzt plötzlich ein Fundus, vor allen Dingen von frei verwendbaren Grafiken und Fotos hat, die man für alles Mögliche verwenden kann.
Entstanden ist das aber glaube ich erstmal aus dieser Problematik heraus, dass man natürlich nicht ein Foto in jede einzelne Sprachversion der einzelnen Wikipedias hochladen wollte, sondern man wollte das irgendwie zentral nutzen. Genau. Es gibt ja im Prinzip für jede Sprache, das hat man ja vor zwei Ausgaben schon, für jede Sprache ein eigenes Wiki. Und dann gibt es halt jetzt noch zusätzlich das Commons-Wiki. Sprich, habe ich ein Foto, dann lade ich es gar nicht erst in die Deutsche hoch, sondern dahin. Das ist sozusagen generell der empfohlene Weg.
Das ist der empfohlene Weg.
Was sind die deutschen Wikipedias?
Ja, wenn es sich um eine Sache handelt, die man nur in der deutschen Wikipedia haben will, zum Beispiel, könnte man sich das überlegen.
Wo sollte das schon sein?
Ja, es gibt manchmal so Geschichten, dass bestimmte Abbildungen, aber selbst da ist es problematisch, wenn man sagt, dass es nach amerikanischem Recht nicht geht. Zum Beispiel diese Sache mit der Perspektivefreiheit. Man kann in Deutschland eine Statue aufnehmen, die irgendwo steht, weil du diesen Platz fotografieren kannst. Wo ist das in Berlin? Das ist eine berühmte Statue, die Marx-Engels-Statue am Marx-Engels-Platz. Natürlich kann jeder das rote Rad aus der Perspektive mit der Statue davon aufnehmen. Das ist in Deutschland erlaubt, aber in den USA nicht. Da könnte man sich jetzt überlegen, dass das nur in die deutsche Wikipedia geht, aber auch nicht. Weil letztlich verantwortlich die Foundation auch für die deutsche Wikipedia ist. Das wäre kein gangbarer Weg, wenn man sagt, das geht nur in Deutschland, aber nicht in den USA. Es greift halt beim Urheberrecht immer das alles, das Amerikanische und das Deutsche. Das ist natürlich schwierig. Eigentlich gibt es keinen Grund, Fotos nur in die deutsche Wikipedia aufzuladen. Es ist bestimmt interessant, dass man die Sache auch in einem anderen Wikipedia verwendet. Es gibt ja auch in Deutschland mehr als die deutsche Wikipedia. Es gibt die plattdeutsche Wikipedia, die das vielleicht auch verwenden will, oder die alemannische Wikipedia. Also es ist eigentlich gut und richtig, wenn man seine Fotos auf Wikimedia-Comments...
Wo wir jetzt eh gerade bei Comments sind, sollten wir vielleicht auch noch mal kurz das Problem mit den Lizenzen ansprechen an der Stelle. Eigentlich ist ja der gesamte Content in der Wikipedia GFDL, also GNU-Free Documentation License, eine abgewandelte Version der Software-Lizenz GPL, sag ich mal.
Also die Bilder eben nicht.
Gut, dann führ du einfach mal aus.
Also bei Wikimedia Commons kann man zwar auch die GNU-FDL wählen, aber diese Lizenz ist ja eigentlich für Software-Dokumentationen gedacht. Und Bilder sind natürlich irgendwie etwas sehr anderes.
Darauf wollt ihr hinaus. Also die Diskussion, also die GFDL wurde halt vom Anfang an verwendet in der Wikipedia, weil es damals einfach das Einzige war, was im Prinzip diesen Freiheitsaspekt, nämlich soll allen zur Verfügung stehen, soll auch kommerziell genutzt werden können und so weiter, dem weitgehend entsprach. Erst später kamen halt die Creative Commons auf. Wie ist denn das jetzt in Commons? Das heißt, Content, den ich hochlade, der kann wahlweise in GFDL oder in einer der Creative Commons lizenziert werden.
Und es kann sogar doppelte Lizenzierungen geben. Also ich kann hergehen und sagen, ich mach das aus GNU-FDL oder gleichzeitig eben auch als Creative Commons, also vielleicht Creative Commons by, also dass der Urheber genannt werden muss, oder mit Creative Commons by und share alike, also dass es weiter so benutzt werden muss. Und gleichzeitig im GNU-FDL. Und dann kann sich der Nutzer aussuchen, was er lieber haben will. Wobei natürlich der Nutzer gut daran tut, die Creative Commons-Lizenz zu nehmen, weil das doch leichter ist in der Benutzung. Und die ist einfach handhabbar. Da kann ich die Quelle nennen und den Urheber. Und dann ist das meistens schon erledigt. Während bei der GNU-FDL, ich ja nun auch zum Beispiel die GNU-FDL in meine Publikation mit abdrucken muss. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du hast eine Zeitung. Ich spreche jetzt gar nicht so von Tageszeitung, die können ihre Bilder kaufen, aber so andere aus dem alternativen Bereich. Oder Schülerzeitung, Newsletter oder Blog. Und du hast da eine schöne Abbildung. Und dann hat die GNU-FDL. Das heißt, du musst dann in deine Schülerzeitung in die jeweilige Ausgabe, wo du sowieso vielleicht nur 16 Seiten zur Verfügung hast, weil du mehr nicht leisten kannst, auch noch vier Seiten GNU-FDL hinten eindrücken. Das geht nicht. Das sieht auch nicht aus. Und das macht keiner. Deshalb ist die GNU-FDL eigentlich vollkommen ungeeignet. Das geht nur bei Texten, die man zitieren kann, weil es da das Zitatrecht gibt. Da kann ich ein bisschen was zitieren, dann ist das okay. Aber bei Bildern ist das eigentlich wirklich nicht handhabbar. Deshalb ist eigentlich auch die GNU-FDL in Commons nicht so wichtig.
Gut, vielleicht noch mal kurz die Sachen mit den Schwesterprojekten. Abschließend gibt es ja DERA-Fiele. Wir können auch ein paar nennen. Wikisource ist für...
Da hat sich auch viel getan.
Was genau?
Da sollen Quellen drin sein. Das kann also auch recht unterschiedlich sein. Insbesondere Quelltexte. Da gibt es jetzt auch eine ganz neue...
Quelltexte im Sinne von Programme.
Nein, nein, Entschuldigung. Das ist in diesem Zusammenhang immer missverständlich. Da sollen Texte, die man sammelt, zum Beispiel der Struffelpeter oder so. Texte, die inzwischen auch frei sind, weil der Autor lang genug tot ist, die sollen dann da zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Aber warum stehen die dann nicht direkt in der Wikipedia unter der Struffelpeter?
Auf der einen Seite würde das die Wikipedia insofern sprengen, weil in der Wikipedia ja Texte stehen sollen, die halt gemeinsam kollaborativ erstellt werden sollen. Der Struffelpeter muss aber nicht kollaborativ erstellt werden, weil der schon da ist. Es gibt aber ein ganz interessantes Problem, und das ist jetzt eigentlich auch etwas, was sehr neu ist und auch sehr aktiv von einer kleinen Gruppe zumindest genutzt wird. Es ist ja so, dass es ganz alte Bücher gibt, die man einscannen kann, aber dadurch sind die ja noch nicht wirklich bearbeitbar. Das heißt, man kann da oft auch, wenn das ältere Handschriften sind, nicht einfach so ein Optical Character Recognition System drüber laufen lassen. Da setzen sich jetzt Leute hin und machen kollaborativ, also in Zusammenarbeit, daraus den Text, also als ASCII-Text oder als UTF-8-Text, also jedenfalls als Text, den man dann auch mit den Mitteln der Datenverarbeitung verarbeiten kann, und stellen das eben her aus der Handschrift. Da gibt es dieses berühmte Rechenbuch, was da mal eingescannt worden ist und was dann eben auf diese Weise weiter existiert. Hätte man das nicht gemacht, also es wäre wahrscheinlich eingescannt worden, dann hätte das in irgendeiner Bibliothek gelegen, wäre nach und nach immer schlechter geworden. Die Bibliothekare hätten dann auch keine Lust mehr gehabt, das irgendwo rauszugeben, weil es dann kaputt geht. Und dann kann man so mit Handschuhen anfassen und kann es kaum lesen. Und so ist das jetzt allgemein zugänglich. Und dererlei Texte gibt es eine ganze Menge. Wenn man also auf die Startseite von Wikisource geht, dann sieht man gleich die Auswahl aus unserem Bestand. Da steht also Handschrift, da ist auch gleich das Rechenbuch, das Andreas Reinhardt genannt. Ja, und wenn man da jetzt draufklickt, kann man das ganz normal lesen. Und natürlich, ich glaube, da ist die Arbeit jetzt schon ziemlich fortgeschritten oder abgeschlossen. Aber bei anderen Projekten kann man sich halt einklinken und selber den Text, den man ja wahrscheinlich dann doch irgendwie entziffern kann, da reinschreiben und jemand anderes, der es vielleicht besser lesen kann, kann das dann korrigieren.
Wo ist da jetzt das Problem?
Das Problem?
Du meintest, es gäbe ja da ein spezifisches Problem bei dieser Erfassung von alten Büchern. Ist es jetzt, dass da sozusagen eine eigene Wertschöpfungskette nochmal losgetreten wird, wenn man sowas transkribiert?
Genau, das Abschreiben oder Transkribieren dieser Texte ist natürlich nicht so ohne Weiteres machbar. Das lässt sich eben nicht automatisieren. Da müssen halt Leute zusammenarbeiten, um das richtig herauszubekommen. Da gibt es auch mehrere Lesungen oder Lesarten, da ist nicht der eine so, der andere so. Dann kann man darüber diskutieren und da ist natürlich ein Wiki sehr geeignet. Also im Grunde ist das die philologische Arbeit, die ein Einzelfilologe in der Vergangenheit gemacht hat und die dann natürlich von anderen Leuten dann kritisiert worden ist, die macht man jetzt zusammen und ist dadurch natürlich einfach besser.
Ich hatte jetzt nämlich irgendwas in Erinnerung, dass solche, bereits von anderen geleistete Transkriptionsarbeit sozusagen dann noch mal als eigene Wertschöpfung dargestellt wird und damit sozusagen auch wiederum Rechte an dieser Übertragung entstanden sind.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Also in der traditionellen Weise hat es einen eigenen Philologen gegeben, der das bearbeitet hat und der hat natürlich dadurch eine Leistung erbracht und hat natürlich auf das, was er da herausgefunden hat, auch das Urheben recht.
Okay, aber in Wikisource wird das genau dadurch umgangen, dass man eben sagt, okay, hier ist der Scan, macht mal.
Genau. Es wird sogar noch viel komplizierter. Also wenn zum Beispiel große klassische Texte, was wir jetzt hier nicht haben, aber was vielleicht dann auch noch mal kommt. Also nehmen wir mal sowas wie die Handschriften von Leonardo da Vinci. Die waren halt in irgendwelchem Staatsbesitz in Italien, sind dann veräußert worden. Zum Beispiel hat Microsoft oder Bill Gates, hat nicht Microsoft Direct, sondern eine andere Firma von Bill Gates, hat das aufgekauft. Und wenn man jetzt den Codex Atlanticus lesen will, dann muss man sich das dort praktisch besorgen gegen Geld. Und das ist natürlich durch so ein Projekt wie Wikisource bei anderen Texten umgangen. Dadurch, dass das jetzt eben alles gemeinfrei ist. Also die Bücher werden sozusagen befreit. Denn gerade mit alten Büchern hat man das Problem, die stehen in der Bibliothek, sind nicht zugänglich. Der Bibliothekar will auch vermeiden, dass jetzt Hunderte von Händen da anfassen, weil die dann kaputt gehen. Das muss sowieso eingeschränkt werden. Und dann gibt es eben zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder das Gerät irgendwann in privater Hand, wenn es interessant genug ist, wie bei Leonardo. Oder aber es wird befreit, indem sich eben Leute zusammensetzen und sagen, wir gucken jetzt mal, dass wir das Buch transkribiert bekommen. Und als Text in Wikisauce veröffentlichen.
Okay, ein weiteres Schwesterprojekt, was hier sicherlich noch erwähnt wird, ist Wikibooks.
Genau.
In dem Zusammenhang. Das ist dann eigentlich auch so was Ähnliches. Nur, dass es sich hier um komplette Bücher handelt.
Ja, da schreiben mal verschiedene Leute zusammen Bücher. Vor allen Dingen Lehrbücher.
Also hier geht es um neue Bücher?
Neue Bücher, genau. Man schreibt also ein neues Buch zusammen mit mehreren. Das ist bei Lehrbüchern immer ganz gut. Denn Lehrbücher sollen ja auch eine gewisse Breite für ein Fach umfassen. Und niemand ist da vielleicht für alles zuständig. Und dann kann man das halt in Zusammenarbeit machen mit mehreren Leuten. Allerdings ist es da auch etwas anders als bei der Wikipedia. Also es gibt dann immer auch jemanden, der vor allen Dingen eine gewisse Verantwortung für das Projekt hat. Und dann eben auch so eine Entscheidung fällt am Ende, was jetzt vielleicht dann auch in der Gegenstand sein kann. Das ist ein bisschen, man muss sich die einzelnen Wikibooks mal anschauen. Das ist dann immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Aber es ist halt in der Regel so, dass es da auch immer für jedes Projekt Leute gibt, die eine größere Verantwortung haben als andere.
Wo du jetzt grad Lehrmittel sagst, dann gibt es ja auch noch Wikiversity auch nochmal als eigenes Subprojekt. Wie steht das jetzt in deinem direkten Zusammenhang?
Ja, das haben viele zunächst geglaubt, dass man Wikiversity gar nicht braucht, weil es ja Wikibooks gibt. Aber Wikiversity geht natürlich noch weiter. Also allein ein Buch macht es ja nicht aus. Also akademische Bildung, da muss man diskutieren, da muss man neue Inhalte eben auch nicht nur als Lehrbuch haben, sondern es müssen Übungen gemacht werden, das muss vielleicht jemand korrigieren und so. Also es gibt diesen ganzen Bereich des E-Learnings, wo es halt mehr als nur Bücher gibt. Und das ist das, was Wikiversity macht. Also da wird eben Lehrer auf hohem Niveau angeboten. Also das beginnt natürlich so auf dem Oberstufenniveau. Also Wikiversity, das erinnert jetzt nur so an Universität. Das ist aber irgendwie alles, was so bei, sagen wir mal, höhere Bildung, also jetzt nicht Grundschule oder so, aber alles, was darüber ist, kann man da einbringen. Und da kann man eben zu verschiedenen Themen halt tatsächlich Kurse anbieten, die halt über ein Lehrbuch hinausgehen, nur mit allem, was dazugehört. Tests und so, also richtig auch Interaktion in Gruppen. Und ja, das ist eben die Aufgabe von Wikiversity.
Das heißt, das wendet sich eigentlich schon mehr an Lehrende als an Schüler?
Nee, also ich kann in Wikiversity, also ein Beispiel, was ich mir mal näher angeschaut habe, da gibt es also einen Leistungskurs Französisch. Die machen das im Bereich Wikiversity. Das heißt also, Lehrer und Schüler arbeiten eben zusammen und stellen Inhalte da in Wikiversity. Das heißt also, der Lehrer gibt Aufgaben, die werden dann da gemeinschaftlich gelöst in Wikiversity. Dann werden halt auch richtige Unterrichtsstunden erarbeitet und da reingestellt. Ja, also alles, was man sonst auch hier in der Oberstufe macht, wird da jetzt eben unterstützt auf dieser Plattform. Also auch kollaborativ. Also Lehrer und Schüler oder Studenten und Professoren zusammen. Das ist eigentlich der Gedanke, der dahintersteht.
Okay, das ist ja schon ein interessanter Spannungsbogen, von diesem, wir sammeln überhaupt erst mal das Wissen. Und jetzt bereiten wir es auch noch auf. Und nebenbei sprechen wir auch noch das gesamte Kulturgut, was nicht schon von irgendwelchen frei herumlaufenden Staaten privatisiert wird, um ihre Kassen zu schonen.
Ja, ich finde das eigentlich eine ganz interessante Tendenz. Wenn du auf der anderen Seite schaust, was zur Zeit in der deutschen Politik abläuft, mit Studiengebühren und so. Da wird gesagt, jeder muss bezahlen, um sonst was lernt, also mehr Wert bekommt, ohne zu bezahlen. Das ist halt so die Ideologie des Neokapitalismus 90er-Jahre. Das wird jetzt in der Universität umgesetzt. Die sind immer ein bisschen langsamer. Die Hochschulpolitik ist eine der langsamsten Politikformen. Die ist noch eingeschlafener als die Gesundheitspolitik. Da gibt es dann immer so zehn Jahre Verzögerung. Und auf der anderen Seite, jetzt so die Sperrspitze, ist das Kollaborative, Open Content, Open Access. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in zehn Jahren auch die deutschen Universitäten das umsetzen und sich da wieder neu organisieren.
Dass wirklich mal eine Wikiversity gegründet wird sozusagen.
Ja, dass hier auch so etwas einfließt und dass eben tatsächlich Leute zusammenarbeiten und eben das nicht alleine über sogenannte Geldbeiträge geht, sondern dass eben dadurch gemeinsam was gemacht wird, dass die Leute sich austauschen und Dinge zusammenbringen und eben kollaborativ arbeiten. Im Grunde ist das schon ein alter Gedanke. Also wenn man sich anschaut, was Willem von Humboldt seinerzeit über die deutschen Universitäten geschrieben hat, dann hat man immer so den Eindruck, naja, das ist irgendwie so, wie man sich das eigentlich jetzt im Internet endlich mal vorstellt.
Na, was hat er denn geschrieben?
Na, er hat darüber geschrieben, dass eben Wissen da sich zustande kommt, dass sich gebildete Leute zusammensetzen und für das Gemeinwohl halt Wissen zusammentragen und dass das eben auch von allen getragen wird. Das klingt dann so ein bisschen altertümlich, wenn man dann schreibt, dass die Nation das bezahlen muss zur Aufgabe der Nation. Aber das muss man aus dem Kontext heraushängen. Damals gab es kein Deutschland in dem Sinne. Aber es gab halt Leute, die Deutsch sprechen und an einer Kultur teilhaben. Und die sollen halt irgendwie sich zusammenfinden. Das war der Gedanke. Ja, und das ist genau das, was jetzt in diesen Wikiprojekten passiert. Also ohne das jetzt hier, das klingt jetzt alles so ein bisschen mit hochtrabend idealistisch. Wir werden ja auch darauf Probleme kommen. Aber das passiert jetzt. Und es wurde eben auch mal Zeit. Gleichzeitig unsere Politiker immer was von Studienbeiträgen und so schwatzen. Sie sind eben einfach noch nicht so weit.
Ja, ich meine, es ist auch insofern wirklich total absurd, dass es eigentlich keinen größeren Wert für diese Gesellschaft gibt als gebildete Bürger. Und in dem Moment, wo wir uns Bildung nicht mehr leisten, können wir uns eigentlich unseren gesamten Staat eh nicht mehr leisten, weil wir gar keine Grundlage mehr haben, auf diesem hohen Level überhaupt zu leben. Das wäre dann doch schon sehr wünschenswert, wenn man hier von der Wiki-Seite da mal ein bisschen Pfeffer rein gibt und Wikiversity scheint mir da schon mal so ein bisschen in die richtige Richtung zu gehen. Gerade so Tutorials und so weiter, um Sachen zu erklären, die man sowieso immer wieder erklären muss. Ich meine, irgendwo, weiß ich auch nicht, muss man nicht immer wieder Lehrbuch, Verlage und Verlager da komplett neu finanzieren, die sollen sich echt mal was anderes einfallen lassen, wie man Geld verdienen kann. Geht dann doch mehr in Dienstleistungen.
Naja, also ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass alle Verlage sterben müssen. Also für die gibt es auch gute Aufgaben.
Ja, natürlich, aber nicht die grundlegenden Sachen. Also ich meine jetzt Strom erklären und so, das gehört halt einfach ins Wiki. Das hat man einfach mal zu wissen und da hat es mal auch ein Tutorial zu geben, wo das ein für alle mal erklärt wird und das hat allen auch zugänglich zu sein. Das ist meine Überzeugung jetzt an der Stelle.
Ja, aber natürlich kann doch ein Verlag hergehen und sagen, ich mache jetzt einen gewissen Mehrwert. Ich nehme zum Beispiel diese Inhalte raus, mache daraus, indem ich in Lektor beschäftige, da das Ganze so ein bisschen auf Fehler nochmal durchgucke, dann vielleicht auch wieder einspeise, sodass eben auch die Community ein Mehrwert dadurch hat. Und produziere daraus ein schönes Buch. Das werden die Leute dann auch kaufen, weil sie sagen, das ist genau das, was ich wissen will. Also es ist automatisch auch durch die Plattformen, Wikiversity und anderes eben auch eine gewisse Werbung da. Und dann sagt man sich, Mensch, das Buch brauche ich.
Ja gut, das sage ich ja, weil die Dienstleistung, die da sozusagen drumherum entsteht, ist, ich produziere dieses Wissen jetzt in einem handhabbaren Format mit einem gewissen Mehrwert, der aus dem Format selbst erwächst und vielleicht auch aus sonstigen Beigaben. Aber das Wissen als solches ist halt nicht…
Genau, das ist der springende Punkt. Das Wissen als solches ist frei, aber man kann eben trotzdem noch Geld verdienen.
Die Gedanken sind frei und man kann trotzdem Kohle machen. So, springen wir doch mal ein bisschen voran. Es gibt dann noch so ein anderes Projekt, was ich sagen würde, das geht nicht unbedingt so in den Wissensbereich. Das war auch von Anfang an eigentlich immer umstritten oder zumindest gab es sehr geteilte Meinungen darüber, wie wichtig das jetzt ist und wie erfolgreich das sein kann. Das ist Wikinews, auf Basis derselben Software wird versucht, Nachrichten zu erzeugen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie du das so einschätzt. Ich kann mich so recht nicht erinnern, in den letzten Jahren irgendwann mal auf einen Eintrag auf Wikinews verwiesen worden zu sein. Was ist denn so deine Erfahrung, wie das Projekt gedient ist?
Tja, wenn ich jetzt sage, dass das nicht so ein wirklicher Erfolg war, hängt das eben auch damit zusammen, dass ich mich nicht wirklich richtig mit Wikinews beschäftigt habe. Ich habe von Anfang an da nicht so das richtige Interesse gehabt. Und es ist auch heute so, wenn ich jetzt angenommen, es gibt einen neuen Krieg in Palästina, dann gucke ich natürlich erst mal in die Wikipedia. Dann mag da ein Link auf Wikinews sein, und dann gucke ich auch danach. Aber der erste Gang ist halt zur Wikipedia und nicht zu Wikinews. Weiß ich nicht. Weil ich sowieso eher automatisch in die Wikipedia gucke. Und weil ich auch ja meist Hintergründe wissen will. Ich will wissen, also wenn zum Beispiel, weiß ich jetzt nicht, sage mal, Arie Charon stirbt. Könnte ja mal passieren. Dann möchte ich jetzt gerne doch mal wissen, wie war das genau mit seiner Krankheitsgeschichte? Wie lange ist er schon im Koma und so? Und das finde ich mit Sicherheit in der Wikipedia. Und naja, dass der tot ist, höre ich sowieso dann im Radio. Entschuldigung, der ist noch nicht tot. Ich will jetzt hier nicht reden. Oder ich habe es jetzt auch nicht genau verfolgt, aber das hätte man, glaube ich, mitbekommen. Aber ich kriege halt da die Hintergründe, die mich eigentlich interessieren. Also es liegt vielleicht daran, dass man gerade hier in der westlichen Welt ja sowieso schon von News heimgesucht wird. Die kommen sozusagen automatisch. Und da muss ich jetzt nicht bei Wikinews nochmal nachschauen.
Ja, also ich habe da so ähnliche Zweifel. Also auch bei mir war häufig die Wikipedia der erste Gang. Wobei Ariel Sharon wäre für mich jetzt nicht so das beste Thema. Ich meine, ich würde natürlich, wenn er dann offiziell mal als tot erklärt wird, weiß ja gar nicht, ob das jemals passiert, ist selbstverständlich der Artikel über Ariel Sharon erstmal so die Referenz, um überhaupt erstmal überall irgendwo hinzugehen.
Das möchte man doch genau wissen. Also wenn jemand stirbt, will man mal wissen, was war das denn für einer, was hat der gemacht? Und dann interessiert man sich plötzlich für Details.
Ja, aber ich erinnere mich noch an einen anderen Effekt. Und zwar war das dieses Zukunftenglück, diese Explosion in Nordkorea. Das ist jetzt auch schon ein, zwei, drei Jahre her. Da gab es halt so eine Explosion. Und wie das so ist in Nordkorea, da kriegt man dann erst mal nicht so einen umfangreichen TV-Bericht dazu. Es wurde halt einfach viel gerätselt. Und wie das so ist, war natürlich diese, das Ereignis war natürlich erstmal ein großer Hype, Explosion in Nordkorea und so. Plus dann war ja auch irgendwie so richtig, nicht so sehr viel daraus zu holen. Und irgendwann verfängt das nicht mehr. Und man muss halt auch mal wieder über Britney Spears reden und so. Und dann wird das eben einfach weggewischt. Und dann verschwand das. Aber trotzdem hat sich das irgendwie noch so im Kopf. Und dann hast du die Frage, okay, da ist was passiert vor ein paar Tagen. Wo kriege ich das her? Geht man dann zu spiegel.de oder Tagesschau oder was, ist es einfach weg. Klar, jetzt kann ich anfangen zu suchen. Nur alles, was ich finde, sind halt genau diese Berichte mit, da ist vielleicht was passiert, da ist vielleicht was passiert, da ist vielleicht was passiert. Und nach fünf Tagen wussten sie immer noch nicht mehr und dann haben sie aufgehört. Das heißt, ich kriege keine Zusammenfassung. In der Wikipedia gab es halt gleich ein, das Zugeenglück von, Link weiß ich jetzt nicht, suche ich nachher noch mal raus, steht auf jeden Fall in den Shownotes. Und da ist dann eben auch immer konkret zusammengefasst und immer auch sozusagen tagesaktuell korrigiert, was denn wirklich geschah im Sinne von, was die tatsächliche Nachrichtenlage war. Und solche Artikel gab es schon einige. Und es gibt ja eine ganze Menge so Ereignisartikel, die sich eigentlich nicht so sehr um so ein Ding, eine Sache oder was weiß ich, handeln sollen eben um etwas, was passiert ist. Terroranschläge 2001, you name it.
Ja, genau.
Ich war halt immer im Zweifel darüber, was dann sozusagen Wikinews noch übernehmen soll an der Stelle.
Ja, genau, weil das eigentlich dann, also gerade die, wie nennt man das, Knowledge in depth heißt das so, in der Encyclopädie Britannica. Wenn man also jetzt nochmal in die Tiefe gehen will, dann braucht man eine Encyclopädie und keine News. Also das ist, News sind eben dann keine News mehr, wenn es irgendwie so aus dem öffentlichen Interesse ein bisschen rausgerückt ist. Natürlich klar, es gibt so Bereiche, das ist ja auch immer die Geschichte, die Noam Chomsky immer wieder erwähnt hat, da mit Ost-Timor, dass da Kriege stattfinden, von denen man hier nichts hört und so. Und da bräuchte man eben alternative News-Kanäle, aber die sind auch noch nicht über Wikinews zu haben. Aber da ist es teilweise wirklich auch gut, mal in die Wikipedia zu schauen, weil die wenigen Experten, denen das sehr am Herzlich, natürlich in Wikipedia schon mal einen Artikel angefangen haben und den auch einigermaßen aktuell halten. Also bei den etwas entlegenden Themen, dann vielleicht eher in der englischen Wikipedia, aber auch in Deutschland gibt es natürlich Experten, also zum Beispiel Kurdistan, Kurden. Also da findest du wirklich in der Wikipedia gute Hintergrundinformationen. Da kann man sich dann auch noch gut, das ist zeitaufwendig, aber wenn man sich wirklich da reinfinden will, dann kann man sich auch noch die ganze Diskussion anschauen. Da wird natürlich dann auch ordentlich gestritten. Oder Ukraine. Also die Ukraine ist jetzt auch wieder so ein Staat, der war vor kurzem aktuell, denke ich, orange in der Revolution, aber dann fragt man sich plötzlich, was ist denn da raus geworden? Und da hilft kein News-Artikel mehr. Und da gibt es aber in der Wikipedia wirklich gute Sachen. Und das sind auch immer so Bereiche, wo man wirklich sagen kann, das ist die Stärke der Wikipedia. Denn das kriegen die anderen Wörterbücher und Lexika nicht so gut hin.
Ja gut, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung. Also ich bin auch weit davon entfernt, jetzt so ein Projekt als gescheiter zu erklären. Weil solange es noch Leute gibt, die darin schreiben, glauben sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch, dass da noch was geht. Und manchmal brauchen gute Ideen auch eine Weile, um sich durchzusetzen. Und vielleicht kommt ja dann noch mal der Moment, wo man so sieht, hier hat es jetzt mal wirklich genau gepasst. Wir werden es sehen. Na gut, vielleicht gibt es noch mehr Schwester-Projekte, Wiki-Quote, zum zitieren, da kann man jetzt ewig drin fangen. Aber ich wollte jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen mehr zur Sprache kommen, welche Probleme es denn derzeit gibt. Weil es gibt ganz offensichtlich Probleme, zumindest gibt es welche, die in der Diskussion sind. Und ein ganz großes Thema war dabei halt das Thema Qualitätssicherung.
Genau, das ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Ich habe da vorhin natürlich am Anfang so enthusiastisch die riesigen Zahlen genannt und der große Zuwachs an Artikeln. Aber da sind natürlich viele Artikel dabei, die halten nicht, was sie versprechen. Und das ist wirklich ein großes Problem. Ich meine jetzt auch kürzlich, wenn man sich die Auswertungen der Lexika im Vergleich anschaut, wie sie kürzlich in der CD waren, in der aktuellen Nummer ist es glaube ich, da sieht man eben, da zeigen sich halt Schwächen. Meine Wikipedia auch. Eben einfach deshalb, weil es, wenn man jetzt einfach irgendeinen Artikel rausnimmt aus einem Wissensgebiet, man an einen Artikel geraten kann, der wirklich schlecht ist. Das kommt halt schon vor. Und das sollte eigentlich nicht so sein. Also irgendwelche Mindeststandards sollten schon gewahrt sein. Es ist auch so, dass es natürlich auch subtile Formen des Vandalismus gibt, die immer wieder mal vorkommen. Man möchte natürlich schon den unbedarften Benutzer davor schützen. Das muss auch gewährleistet sein, sonst funktioniert das nicht. Wenn der Wikipedia immer anhaftet, dass da ein Unsicherheitsfaktor dran ist, dann will der unbedarfte Benutzer das nicht nutzen. Was heißt der unbedarfte Benutzer? Das ist einfach dann lästig, wenn ich immer noch denken muss, Moment, ich muss jetzt kontrollieren, wie ist die Versionsgeschichte und so.
Das macht ja keiner. Man geht halt auf die Wikipedia und was da steht, das ist dann erstmal wahr. Oder man zieht es halt generell in Zweifel und das ist nicht gut. Ich meine, es gab ja von Anfang an schon da auch so ein bisschen Stress in der Wikipedia, also auch schon in ganz frühen Tagen. Es gab da so ein recht frühes kleines Abspaltungsprojekt wikiweise, wo nicht viel daraus geworden ist. Ich fand das auch ein bisschen komisch, weil das sich dann auch auf diesen Enzyklopädie-Stil festgebissen hat und dann diese abkürzungsgeladenen Enzyklopädie-Formen, die meiner Meinung nach ein Auslaufmodell sind, da verfolgt hat. Aber vor kurzem gab es ja damit mit nicht wenig Aufmerksamkeit in der Öffentlichkeit die Ankündigung von dem Larry Sanger, so einem der Mitgestalter der Wikipedia in den ersten Tagen. So ein Schwesterprojekt, in dem Sinne ist es ja nicht. Ein Fork? Mit anderen Worten, er nimmt einfach mal die gesamte Wikipedia und setzt die Inhaltsgestaltung auf eine andere Art und Weise fort.
Ein richtiger Fork ist es ja eigentlich nicht. Beim Fork gehen ja zwei Projekte an irgendeiner Stelle auseinander. Es gibt eine gemeinsame Basis bis zu diesem Punkt. Und dann laufen sie auseinander. Und hier ist es ja so, dass die Wikipedia nach wie vor eine Grundlage auch für Citizendium ist. Citizendium nimmt halt immer Artikel aus der Wikipedia und nimmt sie in das eigene Projekt auf. Die können auch wieder zurückfließen. Und dort in Citizendium sollen sie eben besser werden. Aufgrund gewisser, anderer oder leicht modifizierter Strukturen.
Und was ist denn das für Strukturen?
Ja, das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen das Problem. Also es gibt zunächst mal eine gewisse Aus-, also es wird auf verschiedenen Ebenen gearbeitet. Einmal, wenn man sich anmeldet, muss man seinen Klarnamen nennen und eben auch Referenzen bringen. Also es wird so ein bisschen getestet, zu welchen Gebieten ist jemand Experte. Das soll eben offengelegt werden. Und dann gibt es zusätzlich zu den Administratoren noch so eine besondere Form von Administratoren, die heißen Constables, also Wachtmeister, die darüber wachen, dass die ganze Diskussion in einem gewissen Rahmen bleibt.
Mehr Polizei auf die Datenstraße.
Ja, Constable heißt Polizei. Das hat mich ja eben auch so negativ gestimmt. Jetzt kann man sagen, gut, das ist ein Wort, hätte auch anders heißen können. Aber Wörter, gut, ich bin Sprachwissenschaftler, das sind nicht Wörter für mich so wichtig. Das hinterlässt ein gewisses Gefühl. Und ich finde, wenn man schon von freiem Wissen spricht, und Citizendium ist natürlich ein Projekt, wo es um freies Wissen geht, dann sollte man vielleicht auf solche Strukturen verzichten.
Tja, vielleicht mal ein Polizeiviki damit starten. Da sind ja dann solche Strukturen gewohnt. Ja, also mich überzeugt das auch nicht. Aber schon als dieses Citizendium-Projekt gestartet wurde, war ja diese Qualitätsmaßnahmen-Sicherung in der Diskussion in der Wikipedia-Gemeinde und es gibt da seit längerer Zeit eine Entwicklung. Ich habe sie jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht verfolgt, aber du wahrscheinlich. Ziel ist es, stabile Versionen, war glaube ich der Begriff, in die Wikipedia einzuführen, sodass man sagen kann, okay, ich schaue jetzt nicht auf the latest and greatest version, sozusagen das, was jetzt gerade frisch von einem 14-jährigen Schüler editiert wurde, eine halbe Stunde nachdem an der Schule von allen ausgelacht wurde, sondern ich gucke auf irgendeine Version davon. Also wie soll das funktionieren?
Ja, also bei den stabilen Versionen gibt es, muss man zwei Formen unterscheiden. Das sind einmal die gesichteten Versionen und die geprüften Versionen. Das Ganze gibt es noch nicht. Also die Konzepte gibt es schon. Und es ist nur noch nicht umgesetzt, aber das wird in Kürze erfolgen.
Also in einigen Worten, es wird an der Software gearbeitet, um ein Konzept, auf das man sich schon weitgehend geeinigt hat, umzusetzen.
Jimmy Wales hat uns das für Ende 2006 versprochen, vollmundig Mitte 2006. Und das hat so nicht funktioniert, weil die Entwickler eben auch andere Prioritäten hatten.
Software ist halt fertig, wenn sie fertig ist.
Es kommt 2007, da bin ich eigentlich ziemlich sicher. Es gibt zwei Konzepte, die sogenannten gesichteten Versionen und die geprüften Versionen. Das klingt erstmal ein bisschen komisch. Das Wort gesichtete Version ist auch seltsam. Aber die englische Bezeichnung ist noch seltsamer. Ihre Führende heißt es nämlich non-vandalisierte Version. Das ist aber eine schlechte Bezeichnung, weil das impliziert, dass die anderen alle vandaliert sind. Das sind die gesichteten Versionen und dann die geprüften Versionen. Das ist dann noch mal eine Stufe schärfer geprüft. Bei den geprüften Versionen geht es darum, dass im Inhalt keine groben Fehler vorhanden sind und keine groben Auslassungen, die so ähnlich funktionieren wie Fehler. Dazu braucht man bei der Prüfung natürlich Experten.
Jetzt wird es knifflig.
Das ist knifflig und das ist auch schwierig. Aber die andere Idee, die ist eigentlich ziemlich genial, dass man da nicht von Anfang an drauf gekommen ist, das sind die gesichteten Versionen. Da geht es einfach nur darum, dass jemand, der nicht Experte sein muss, sondern gewissen Stellenwert in der Wikipedia hat, der ist aber relativ gering, also die Schwelle ist sehr gering. 30 Tage muss der dabei gewesen sein und muss mindestens 30 Edits gemacht haben. Dann wird er freigeschaltet für das Sichten von Versionen. Und dann guckt er sich so eine Version an.
Automatisch?
Ja, das soll automatisch gehen. Und dann guckt er sich so eine Version an und setzt unten so ein Häkchen oder so ein Flag, wie man da neu Deutsch sagt, und sagt, die ist gesichtet. Das heißt, das ist so weit in Ordnung, wie man das als nicht Experte beurteilen kann. Das heißt also, es gibt keinen offensichtlichen Vandalismus und es gibt eben auch nicht unvollständige Sätze oder so.
Das bezieht sich aber nur auf die gerade aktuell eingeblendete Version.
Jaja, für eine Version setzt er dieses Häkchen.
Das heißt, er ruft auch eine explizite Version auf?
Na, er guckt sich die aktuelle Version an und sagt, aha, das ist in Ordnung, ich setze jetzt mal ein Häkchen.
Ja gut, aber in dem Moment kann ja schon die nächste Änderung drin sein.
Nee, dann ist es aber eine neue Version. Aber die Version, die er sozusagen abgestempelt hat, die bekommt oben so einen gelben Punkt und da steht dann, diese Version ist gesichtet und enthält eben keinen offensichtlichen Vandalismus oder wie auch immer man das dann formuliert. Und damit ist...
Und das reicht schon, wenn einer das macht?
Ja, genau.
Aber ich meine, wenn das wirklich eine automatische Freischaltung ist, also einen Account zu erzeugen, der jetzt irgendwie 30 Edits macht...
Na ja, 30 Edits, 30 Tage, das ist schon eine gewisse Hürde.
Ja, aber die 30 Edits kann ich ja an einem Tag machen, dann warte ich noch mal 30 Tage.
Also ich habe schon 500 Edits gemacht. Also ich glaube auch, dass da noch einer draufguckt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht nötig, dass mehrere Leute es gesichtet haben müssen.
Genau, also einmal setzt einer diesen Flag. Wenn jetzt auffällt, dass da jemand Unsinn macht und Flag setzt, wo keine hingehören, dann kriegt er natürlich seinen Status wieder aberkannt. Und da ist natürlich so eine gewisse soziale Kontrolle da. Denn das ist natürlich schlecht. Man will ja kein gefallener Editor sein. Man möchte natürlich gerne dieses Privileg, Sachen sichten zu dürfen, unbedingt behalten. Deshalb denke ich, wird es erstmal viele gesichtete Artikel geben. Und ich denke, die Leute, die das machen, werden auch sorgfältig damit umgehen. Also man kann nicht einfach, wie das jetzt ist, die Vandalen sind, das haben wir ja nun auch, das kann man ja mit den Tools, die auf dem Tools-House sind, ganz gut nachvollziehen. Vandalen kommen entweder per IP oder klicken sie schnell in den Account. Weil eben die IP, das ist vielleicht doch nicht so gut. In der englischen Wikipedia ist ja auch das IP-Editing so ein bisschen eingeschränkt. Dann kann ich einen neuen Artikel anlegen.
IP-Editing heißt, man arbeitet ohne Account einfach los.
Es gibt also auch Vandalen, die klicken sich in den Account. Aber dann sind das meistens Leute, die neu dazugekommen sind. Denn sobald sie als Vandalen auffallen, werden sie wieder gesperrt. Also im Augenblick gibt es noch keine Vandalen, die wird es dann vielleicht auch geben, die erst mal 30 Tage lang Geduld aufbringen, 30 vernünftige Edits machen und dann, wenn sie freigeschaltet sind, plötzlich loslegen.
Okay, damit wird dieses Rüde ins Haus fallen und alles kaputt schlagen, wird schon mal verhindert. Aber was ja eigentlich bei dieser Qualitätsdebatte sehr viel mehr, ich meine, wenn er jetzt drinsteht, fuck you, was weiß ich, dann ist das ja auch irgendwo offensichtlich. Aber worum es ja immer wieder ging in der Diskussion, das waren insbesondere Artikel in Biografien von Personen, die halt nicht ganz offensichtlich, sondern eben sehr unoffensichtlich gefälscht wurden, was weiß ich, da wurde halt irgendwas, was drin stand, rausgenommen, irgendwann eine Bedeutung umgedreht. So eine kleine Editierung fällt nicht groß auf.
Es gab einen deutschen Politiker, ich nenne jetzt mal keinen Namen, da stand dann also einfach so drin, er hat zwei Kinder oder zwei Söhne, zwei Töchter, ist ja egal, die beide den Hauptschulabschluss erworben haben. Da stand da Wochen, Monate drin, bis einem dann aufgefallen ist, dass es ein bisschen komisch klingt und natürlich ein Vandalismus war, also ein ganz dezenter Halt, aber das würde natürlich jemandem auffallen, der da sein Kreuzchen untersetzt. Wenn er das durchliest und dann so was sieht, dann wird er das beheben.
Ja gut, aber er weiß es ja in dem Sinne nicht. Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass die beiden Kids tatsächlich den Hauptschulabschluss geschafft haben.
Dann wären sie wahrscheinlich auch.
Na ja, so schwierig ist das.
So schwierig ist das nicht, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie mehr geschafft.
Ja gut, aber woher weiß man das dann? Ich meine, das ist ja etwas, wenn ich mir so ein, wenn ich mir, also wenn ich mir allein schon die Artikel, die ich jetzt auch wirklich mal lese, um was zu lernen, da habe ich ja einfach das Problem, dass für mich dann irgendwie fast alles neu ist. Das nehme ich natürlich erst mal so hin. Und gerade so bei Politikern und so, was weiß ich, was die alles gemacht haben. Und gerade wenn ich da irgendwie lese, das ist eine rohe Vergangenheit, dann freue ich mich natürlich erst mal.
Jaja, aber dann kommen wir auf den, da sind wir dann in der anderen Liga der geprüften Versionen. Also das soll ja auch noch dazu kommen, dass man halt tatsächlich auch die Version überprüft. Nur das geht nicht so massenweise. Eine Überprüfung von Artikeln, da müssen halt wirklich Experten ran. Die müssen erst mal gefunden werden.
Wo kommen die her?
Ja, das ist eben die große Frage.
Wie sieht da die Diskussion aus?
Ist noch umstritten. Also da gibt es die einen, die sagen, ja wir haben natürlich schon mal in der Wikipedia Experten. Dann müssten die aber auch ihren Namen offenlegen. Da gibt es viele, die sagen, ich will aber doch lieber als IP, nicht als IP, mit einem Nick hier nur firmieren und nicht mit meinem Klarnamen. Ja, dann Experten von außen. Sie sind natürlich nicht so leicht zu gewinnen, weil natürlich jemand erst mal so ein bisschen die Wikipedia erkennen muss, bevor er sich dafür begeistern kann und so. Gut, da muss man auch dran arbeiten, aber da wird man nicht Massen finden.
Aber auch die Experten müssen ja von irgendeinem Experten berufen werden.
Genau, also da soll die Community natürlich entscheiden. Und das ist natürlich auch wieder ein gewisses Problem. Aber eigentlich müsste die Auswahl der Experten in der Hand der Community bleiben. Anderen Weg gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Was wäre denn, wenn man dieses Modell dieser gesichteten Versionen zunächst einmal auf eine andere Stufe stellt und sagt, wenn ein Artikel von einer Person als OK freigeschaltet wird, dann enthält er halt keinen Vandalismus. Wenn 30 Leute sagen, der ist aber OK, dann scheint der schon eine gewisse Glaubwürdigkeit zu haben. Und wenn so und so viele Leute sagen, diese Version scheint mir aber wirklich auch noch ganz prima zu sein, also in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch ein Rating vergeben, sodass einfach der Wert des Artikels immer weiter ansteigt und nicht so dieses Digitale ist OK, ist richtig, ist nicht richtig, weil irgendwie wissen wir ja auch, jede Darstellung kann angezweifelt werden. Und so mit dieser Wahrheit, das ist einfach generell ein schweres Feld. Und warum nicht in diese Richtung?
In gewisser Weise gibt es das ja schon. Also die Diskussionsseiten sind ja eigentlich dafür gedacht und das funktioniert auch so.
Ja, aber die kann man sicher nicht durchlesen.
Natürlich, also da könnte man darüber nachdenken, tatsächlich nochmal so eine numerische Bewertung draufzuführen. Und tatsächlich soll die Erweiterung...
Sternchen.
Ja, Sternchen, gut. Tatsächlich soll die Erweiterung der Software, der Media-Wiki-Software auch in die Richtung gehen. Also da soll es noch mehr geben, als nur dieses eine Kreuzchen gesichtet. Da gibt es auch noch die Idee, die auch von Mitgliedern des Boards, der Foundation, wohl sehr gerne gesehen wird, dass es verschiedene Arten von Flags gibt. Dass sich Leute auch den Artikeln unter verschiedenen Aspekten anschauen. Und da muss man mal sehen, es wird auf jeden Fall eine Erweiterung der Wikimedia-Software geben, die auch solche Sachen letztlich ermöglicht. Da muss man mal sehen, was man davon umsetzt. Es ist natürlich immer ein schwieriger Diskussionsprozess. Das zeigt schon gerade die Diskussion um die geprüften Artikel. Also da ist eigentlich noch völlig unklar, wie die Experten gewonnen werden sollen, was das für Leute sind und so weiter, wie man auch kontrolliert, ob die wirklich Experten sind. Und ich meine, Experten sind an sich ja auch problematisch. Also da gibt es bei den Wissenschaftlern immer Schulen, die miteinander im Streit liegen.
Ja, ich freu mich, wer wird denn der Experte zu dem Artikel Adolf Hitler?
Man hätte gerne Joachim Fest natürlich gewonnen, der ist aber inzwischen gestorben. Das ist schwierig. Aber man könnte sich natürlich so etwas angucken, wenn es irgendwie tatsächlich Autoren gibt, die sich zu einem bestimmten Thema auch sonst sehr profiniert haben, dass man die vielleicht fragt, ob sie auch mal auf den Wikipedia-Artikel schauen könnten. Und wenn da eben irgendwo dabei steht, geprüft von und der hat eine gewisse Autorität, dann hat das auch eine gewisse Außenwirkung.
Okay, wir werden sehen, wie sich das entwickelt. Noch gibt es das Feature nicht, aber es befindet sich in der Diskussion. Und ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass die Frage Qualitätssicherung einfach eine große Rolle spielt in der Wikipedia-Gemeinde.
Ja, nicht nur in der Wikipedia-Gemeinde. Man muss sich ja vorstellen, wenn die Wikipedia immer bedeutender wird und sich immer mehr Leute darauf verlassen, ist einfach ein Fehler in der Wikipedia ziemlich schlimm.
Klar, ich meine, dass die Öffentlichkeit das als Problem angesehen hat, das ist ganz offensichtlich. Die Frage ist ja nur, wie sieht das die Community? In die schaut natürlich keiner so ohne Weiteres rein. Kann ja nicht sein, dass die alle die Zunge hochstrecken und sagen, wir sind einfach wie Uirol.
Die Diskussion um Qualität ist die Hauptdiskussion. Wir kamen nur auf die stabilen Versionen, da gibt es dann noch viel mehr Maßnahmen. Da gibt es ja Maßnahmen, die es auch schon länger gibt, mit Wettbewerben, Schreibwettbewerben. Exzellente Artikel.
Jetzt gibt es auch den Artikel-freien Sonntag?
Genau, es gibt da ein paar Aktionen. Es gab ja schon mal die Aktion Frühjahrsputz, das heißt wirklich so, ich habe das nochmal nachgeschaut. Und dann, dass man eben in einer bestimmten Periode nicht unbedingt neue Artikel schafft, sondern sich vor allem darauf konzentriert, das, was da ist, zu sichten. Dann Artikel-freier Sonntag, das war der Vorschlag, dass man freiwillig oder sogar durch Einschränkungen in der Software an einem Sonntag eben keine neuen Artikel erstellt, sondern eben sich darauf konzentriert, vorhandene Artikel zu bearbeiten. Da gibt es natürlich eine große Diskussion. Dann gibt es dann einige, die sagen, nein, ich will mich jetzt aber trotzdem nicht in meinen Freiheiten beschränken lassen. Dann gibt es dann auch das Ende des Wiki-Prinzips, wenn man da jetzt sagt, also jetzt keine neuen Artikel.
The end of the world, the end of the Wiki.
Freiheit ist halt immer ein hohes Gut. Es hat diese Aktionen gegeben, dann auf freiwilliger Basis. Es ist dann die Frage, wie erfolgreich das immer war. Ich habe dummerweise den Artikel freien Sonntag verpasst. Das ist dann auch immer schade, aber so ist das halt. Es soll dann jetzt auch eine erweiterte Kampagne geben, die heißt Nichts Neues. Nichts Neues heißt, dass man wirklich für eine bestimmte Zeit, das kann vielleicht länger als ein Sonntag sein, vielleicht eine Woche oder sogar einen Monat, eben tatsächlich sich darauf konzentriert, erstmal Vorhandenes zu verbessern und nicht etwas Neues zu schaffen und damit eben auch neue Probleme zu schaffen.
Gut, Qualitätssicherung ist in der Diskussion. Was ich mich jetzt noch frage ist, wie steht es um die anderen Diskussionen? Anderer, gerade jetzt hier im CCC-Radio etwas schwer zu diskutieren, der Fall ist diese Auseinandersetzung, um den Artikel zu tronnen. Dem Hacker, der vor einiger Zeit unter mysteriösen Umständen ums Leben kam. Da gibt es viele Theorien und Auffassungen, die wir jetzt hier gar nicht aufweilen wollen. Tatsache war, er kam natürlich durch seinen Tod dann in die Medien. Das wurde in vielen Stellen aufbereitet. Es gab Kontroversen um Bücher, Hörbücher, generell die Darstellung in der Öffentlichkeit. Letztes Jahr entfachte sich dann ein weiterer Streit, dass der Klarname von ihm in der Wikipedia auftauchte. Die Leute, die diese Position vertreten, dass das auch okay sei, meinten, es sei eine öffentliche Person. Eine öffentliche Person muss auch öffentlich genannt werden können und Ende der Diskussion, sage ich mal.
Da gibt es tatsächlich verschiedene Auffassungen.
Da gab es verschiedene Auffassungen. Da gab es eine riesen Kontroverse, das Fass werde ich jetzt auch nicht komplett aufmachen. Aber es ist einfach ganz offensichtlich, dass natürlich dieses Arbeiten in der Wikipedia ein Arbeiten in der Öffentlichkeit ist. Und jedes geschriebene Wort, was dort auftaucht, ist automatisch auf Tausenden von Backup-Servern, ist in der ewigen Historie dieser Datenbank hineingeschrieben. Und die Auseinandersetzung, also die eigentliche Diskussion selbst, war das wahrscheinlich das Ätzendste an der ganzen Geschichte, weil sich da einfach Untiefen aufgetan haben in der Gemeinschaft, auf allen Seiten, sowohl bei Vertretern als auch gegen Vertreter, wo man auch nicht mehr so das Gefühl hatte, dass es da groß um die Sache geht, sondern dass da religiöse Kriege ausgefunden werden. Wie hast du das reflektiert und wie wird damit jetzt umgekehrt?
Ich glaube, dass viele Leute damals nicht richtig bemerkt haben. Und was auch heute vielen Leuten nicht klar ist, ist, dass eben jede Aktion in der Wikipedia wirklich in der Öffentlichkeit ist. Das ist nicht irgendwie ein Gespräch im Wohnzimmer, sondern das ist wirklich Öffentlichkeit und bleibt im Gedächtnis der Wikipedia. Also ist schriftlich da ja immer vorhanden, wird durch Suchmaschinen gefunden. Das ist vielen Leuten nicht klar. Deshalb verhalten sie sich im Kindergarten oder im Sandkasten. Aber es ist eben anders. Das muss vielleicht auch klarer werden. Das ist vielleicht auch in der Aktion klarer geworden. Aber die Diskussion mit diesem Einzelfall verstellt natürlich den Blick, dass es da wirklich auch hunderte von Fällen gibt. Also ein wichtiges Problem ist eben, dass zum Beispiel Straftäter in Deutschland auch das Recht haben, wenn sie ihre Strafe abgesessen haben, sondern auch wieder in die Gesellschaft integriert zu werden. Das heißt, man kann natürlich, wenn gerade ein Mord passiert ist, erstmal die Namen der Mörder eventuell nennen, erstmal mutmaßlich, dann sind die irgendwann verurteilt. Das steht natürlich in der Zeitung. Was weiß ich, Peter Müller hat diesen schlimmen Mörchelmord begangen. Und dann ist er halt zu 20 Jahren verurteilt. Nach 20 Jahren hat er seine Strafe abgesessen. Und dann soll er natürlich in irgendeiner Weise wieder vollwertiges Mitglied der Gesellschaft werden. Und wenn dann in der Wikipedia aber immer noch steht, dass dieser Peter Müller, also Peter Müller ist natürlich ein aller Weltname, das kann natürlich jeder sein, aber es könnte natürlich ein spezifischer Name sein, dass der ein Mörder ist, dann kann der einfach nicht sich wieder in die Gesellschaft einfinden nach den 20 Jahren Strafe. Weil dieser Markel immer, der verfolgt den immer. Und da gibt es natürlich tatsächlich im deutschen Recht die Auflage, dass dann wirklich auch der die Chance haben sollte, wieder in die Gesellschaft zurückzufinden. Und dann müssen natürlich die Informationen gelöscht werden. Das ist aber ein Feature, das von der Wikipedia nicht vorgesehen ist. Das soll alles in der Geschichte bleiben. Und da muss eben jemand hergehen und da eben nachher löschen. Und zwar so löschen, dass nicht der nächste wieder kommt und das wieder reinsetzt. Da muss also nicht nur gelöscht werden, sondern auch aufgepasst werden. Und der normale Nutzer weiß ja vielleicht gar nicht, dass dieser Mörder jetzt rehabilitiert ist und entlassen ist. Er denkt sich, Moment mal, dieser Mörder von damals, der hieß doch sowieso und das steht da nicht. Das muss man doch reinsetzen.
Und dann kommt das immer wieder und dann nimmt wieder jemand raus und dann gibt es großen Streit. Ist das überhaupt ein lösbares Problem?
Ja, da muss man jetzt mal wirklich drüber nachdenken. Ich halte das für sehr schwer lösbar. Weil das ist wirklich ein großes Problem der Wikipedia. Man braucht wahrscheinlich tatsächlich irgendwie, du hast es mal gebracht, dass da irgendwo in Florida unterirdisch das Ministerium der Information sitzt und dass die dann immer genau aufpassen und dann irgendwie die Information, die drin stehen darf, löschen muss. Tatsächlich ist das, ich sehe eigentlich keine andere Lösung. Da muss es tatsächlich so eine Gruppe geben. Die müssen wahrscheinlich auch hoch bezahlt werden. Wikipolizei.
Ich war damals in der Diskussion auch sehr gespalten. Das kann ich auch gerne noch mal zum Besten geben. Weil ich war, wie soll man sagen, es gibt ja zwei Sachen, die aufeinandertreffen. Das eine ist halt dieses Daten wollen frei sein, Informationen wollen frei sein, es gibt ein Interesse an einer öffentlichen Information. Das ist ja auch so ein Credo des Graus Computer Club. Öffentliche Daten nutzen, private Daten schützen. Das Spannungsfeld entsteht halt genau da, wo es einfach schwierig ist zu sagen, ist eine Information jetzt privat und ist sie öffentlich. Vor allem, wenn sie, wie in diesem Beispiel, den wir jetzt genannt haben, eigentlich beides ist. Es ist eine private Information in der Öffentlichkeit, die vielleicht für einen bestimmten Kontext, einen bestimmten Zeitraum auch ein Aufenthaltsrecht hat in der Öffentlichkeit ist. Allein schon, weil es wahrscheinlich auch faktisch nicht verhinderbar ist, aber dann später vielleicht eben anders. Wir hatten jetzt bei dieser Tronsache das Problem, er war zwar tot, dann konnte man jetzt viel mit Persönlichkeitsrecht und lalalala reden, aber ich will das jetzt gar nicht rechtlich aufziehen. Es war einfach das Problem, dass dadurch, dass der Name selbst, sein realer Name sehr selten war, die Eltern einfach laufend noch damit konfrontiert wurden und daraus konkret zu leiden hatten. Was ihnen dann auch irgendwie wieder zum Vorwurf gemacht worden ist, ist hintenrum, weil was mischen sie sich denn da ein? Das ist alles ein extremes privates Drama gewesen. Ich habe halt am Anfang mir die Situation angeschaut und dachte mir so, oh mein Gott, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie anfangen, da jetzt eine Zensurbehörde zu schaffen, das war wahrscheinlich das Beispiel, was du genannt hast, dass jetzt irgendwie bestimmte Worte dürfen nicht in die Wikipedia geschrieben werden, dann sah ich halt schon so automatische ganze Server-Schränke wie bei der CIA, die einfach nichts anderes tun, als automatisch Zensur auszuüben. Das ist sozusagen meine erste Reaktion gewesen. Meine zweite, spätere Reaktion war einfach die Betrachtung von der privaten Seite her. Wie kann man es schaffen, dass dieser Anspruch auf eine Privatsphäre, den ich einfach genauso als sehr wichtig ansehe, überhaupt noch sichergestellt werden kann? Ich habe da keine gute Antwort drauf.
Das ist wirklich ein ganz schwieriges Feld. Ich meine, es darf natürlich nicht so sein, dass plötzlich irgendwelche Informationen verschwinden. Aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass gewisse Informationen für eine gewisse Zeit eben auch möglicherweise im Archiv sein müssen. Nicht gleich zugänglich, aber dann vielleicht nach einer gewissen Zeit, wenn 100 Jahre später irgendwelche Historiker wissen wollen, wie war das denn da genau, dass die natürlich die Möglichkeit haben, an Informationen ranzukommen. Und das ist ja jetzt zur Zeit der Fall. Die können in die Archive gehen und finden dann auch nach langer Recherche irgendwo raus, wer wen umgebracht hat. Weil das natürlich irgendwo verzeichnistisch ist, aber das ist eben nicht für die Öffentlichkeit jederzeit zugänglich, dass wenn ich jetzt nach dem Namen suche, sofort mir diese ganze Geschichte da ins Gesicht fällt.
Aber vielleicht ist diese Zeit jetzt auch einfach vorbei. Wir leben jetzt in der Google-Zeit und jetzt wird nicht mehr nach Jesus, sondern nach Google gerechnet und die Jahre schreiten voran. Wir müssen jetzt lernen, neue Methoden zu entwickeln, um eben mit dieser unbegrenzten Datenverfügbarkeit und damit auch dieser unbegrenzten Geschichtsverfügbarkeit irgendwie klarzukommen.
Ja, aber wir müssen aber trotzdem Lösungen finden für solche Probleme. Also es ist sicherlich schwierig, aber da muss man sich Gedanken machen. Man könnte nicht einfach sagen, so die Welt hat sich verändert und jetzt wird Recht zu Unrecht und Unrecht zu Recht. Also es ist vielleicht sinnvoll, dass es gewisse Gesetze mal gegeben hat, die leicht umzusetzen waren, die sind jetzt halt schwerer umzusetzen. Da muss man sich halt, na nicht Gesetze, sondern es gibt Recht, was im Recht bleiben muss und da muss man halt den Rahmen finden, wie man das letztlich umsetzt.
Okay, also wir fordern, dass sich jemand Gedanken macht.
Genau, es machen sicher viele Leute Gedanken.
Ja, wir machen uns auch Gedanken, aber man kommt in der Diskussion nicht weit. Ich meine, es hat auch sicherlich mit unserer Alarm-Medien-Kompetenz in der Summe was zu tun, nicht nur am Einzelnen, sondern da muss eigentlich auch ein gesellschaftlicher Prozess einsetzen und ich glaube, der braucht noch eine Weile.
Der braucht sehr lange. Also ich hatte das ja vorhin mit den Universitäten angesprochen, weil ich ja so gesagt habe, die brauchen länger als die Gesundheitsreform. Aber die Reform von Recht, das braucht noch viel, viel länger. Also bis die Rechtsanwälte, Staatsanwälte, Richter bemerkt haben, was sich da tut und bis die das verstanden haben, worüber sie dann sofort zu entscheiden haben, das ist dann schon ein langer Prozess. Irgendwie habe ich auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sich in Deutschland die Rechtsprechung auch so ein bisschen drumrum drückt.
So, vielleicht nochmal so ein, zwei Sachen und nochmal so ein bisschen auf Community auch zu bleiben. Also was auch immer wieder so ein schwieriges Feld ist, ist so diese Sache mit den Inkludisten und den Exkludisten. Ich fand das am Anfang noch ganz putzig, aber es stellt sich eigentlich immer wieder so als Problem raus. Diese Frage, was ist jetzt würdig in der Wikipedia verzeihen zu werden? Da gibt es die eine Fraktion der Inkludisten, die sagen, alles was ich mit Worten beschreiben kann, das kann ich auch in die Wikipedia reinschreiben, weil wenn ich es nicht tue, tut es jemand anders. Und irgendwann, egal wie oft es gelöscht wird, es wird dann sowieso da wieder stehen, weil wenn Leute es nachschlagen wollen und es ist nicht da, dann schreiben sie es halt rein, so funktioniert das WG. Dann gibt es die Fraktion der Exkludisten, die halt sagen, nein, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie jedes Wort und jede Buchstabenkombination auf diesem Planeten da reinschreiben, dann sinkt der Gesamtwert, die Wikipedia.
Das ist, wie gesagt, ich gehöre ja zu den Radikal-Inkludisten. Also ich möchte ja wirklich viel da drin haben, weil ich einfach die Erfahrung gemacht habe. Ich kann, ich habe da praktisch neben meinem Büro...
Radikal-Inkludist, das ist doch mal was für die Visitenkarte, oder?
Naja, ich habe halt in Fußwegstdistanzen zu meinem Büro eine riesige Universitätsbibliothek, wo ich halt wirklich das spezielle Wissen nachschlagen kann. Wenn ich aber nun wissen will, wie war das denn mit den Simpsons? Wann ging das los? Kann ich nicht. Da brauche ich die Wikipedia. Da bin ich froh, dass ich die Information habe. Ich frage mich heute auch, wie war das in 1989? Da hätte ich auch was über die Simpsons wissen wollen. Und da konnte ich das nicht einfach nachschlagen. Da muss sich kompliziert, da ging es ja schon mit dem Usenet, da konnte man da was posten und dann hat vielleicht irgendjemand was geantwortet, da hatte ich überhaupt keine Handhabe zu sagen, ist das richtig oder falsch, weil da einer mir was geantwortet hat. Es wäre wirklich schwer gewesen, über solche Themen was nachzuforschen.
Ja, schön, dass du das sagst. Ich habe was in der Wikipedia gefunden, ich sage jetzt mal nicht was, weil es egal ist, aber ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich 1989 im Usenet das gefragt habe, ob das jemand weiß. Keine Antwort. Und irgendwie 15 Jahre später, 16, 17 Jahre später, auf einmal steht es halt einfach auf so einer Webseite. Und das ist schon eine schöne Erfahrung. Aber jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei den Bejubelungen des Wikipedias. Mir ging es jetzt ein bisschen mehr darum, Löschdiskussion. Das ist etwas, was immer wieder viel Feuer entfacht. Irgendjemand sagt, was ist denn das jetzt hier für ein Scheiß. Das hat jetzt aber hier mal wegzukommen, weil das verschmutzt hier unsere Festplatten. Dann wird eine riesige Löschdiskussion angetreten. Es gibt da ja zumindest einen definierten Prozess. Man kann nicht einfach irgendwas löschen. Das gibt es auch, das Schnelllöschen. Vielleicht kannst du ja einfach mal kurz erzählen, was so die Vorgehensweise beim Löschen von Informationen so ist.
Es gibt also zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder jemand stellt einen Schnelllösch-Antrag. Das ist immer dann der Fall, wenn es offensichtlich ist, dass das da nicht eingehört.
Gefahr im Verzug.
Dann kann das eben auch schnell gelöscht werden. Das ist aber eher die Ausnahme. Was heißt die Ausnahme? Es hängt davon ab. Wenn da wirklich ein Artikel reingestellt wird, der irgendwie auch den Anschein hat, ein Artikel zu sein, dann geht es nicht, dass man einfach Schnelllösch-Antrag stellt. Das kann man natürlich versuchen. Da wird man aber sofort scheitern. Sondern dann muss eine richtige Löschdiskussion gemacht werden. Dann muss man hergehen und sich eben Gedanken machen. Dann wird das halt diskutiert in einem gewissen Zeitrahmen. Und je nachdem, wie dann da das Meinungsbild ist, wird dann gelöscht, dann nicht gelöscht.
Hast du als Radikal-Includist schon mal in einer Löschdiskussion teilgenommen, wo du dafür warst, dass gelöscht wird?
Eigentlich nicht. Also bei Schnelllösch-Anträgen, da konnte ich das verstehen. Aber bei der richtigen Löschdiskussion, ja gut, es gibt... Ja, doch, es gab schon. Es gibt da immer das...
Fällt dir das Lemma gerade ein, dass ich die Seite neu anlegen kann?
Nein, ich sag das lieber nicht. Man weiß ja, was dann passiert. Also ein gewisses Problem sind die sogenannten Selbstdarsteller. Da kommt also jemand her und sagt, oh, Wikipedia, warum stehe ich da denn nicht drin?
Ich bin doch so berühmt und so bekannt.
Ich bin doch so bekannt und berühmt. Und dann schreibt er da natürlich irgendwas rein.
Okay, Peter Müller wieder. Ist ein hübscher Mensch aus Benzin, Friedrichshain.
Ja, ist ein Schüler, der seit Oktober letzten Jahres auch bei der Wikipedia mitarbeitet. So ein Artikel. Das geht natürlich nicht. Also so schön das ist. Und vielleicht wird er auch mal irgendwann so berühmt, dass er Peter Müller, dass der da rein muss. Aber natürlich nicht so schnell. Und da habe ich natürlich dann auch gesagt, nö.
Okay, aber wo fängt es dann an? Weil es gab jetzt solche Löschdiskussionen auch um jüngst um eine junge Politikerin, die schon auch in den Medien reflektiert wurde. Und auch da gab es dann gleich wieder große Panik und oh Gott, das ist dann auch noch ein Wiedergänger. Das ist dann, wenn sozusagen mal schon mal was gelöscht wurde und dann hat es wieder jemand angelegt, dann soll die Geotinie gleich noch etwas schneller fallen. Was ist denn da jetzt der Maßstab? Gibt es einen?
Ja, es gibt natürlich gewisse Kriterien, die entwickelt wurden, die von manchen auch so als unverrückbare Regeln interpretiert werden. Was also ein Verein nur aufgenommen werden kann, wenn er also mindestens so und so viele Mitglieder hat. Und da wird natürlich dann laufend auch jetzt noch diskutiert, wie viele Mitglieder das denn sein müssen. Also es werden halt Kriterien entwickelt. Oder zum Beispiel jemand, der halt Professor an einer deutschen Universität ist, ist allein deshalb enzyklopädiewürdig. Da kann man natürlich auch darüber diskutieren, ob man dann schon enzyklopädiewürdig ist. Aber das wird zum Beispiel angenommen. Jetzt ist die Frage, jemand, der ein zweites Beruf veröffentlicht hat oder eine sogenannte Habilitation gemacht hat, also praktisch die Voraussetzung hat, ein Professor zu werden, aber vielleicht auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil er unbequem ist, sowas nicht geworden ist, ist ja nicht enzyklopädiewürdig. Und da wird halt darüber diskutiert und auch darüber gestritten. Also es werden Kriterien entwickelt. Das ist auch wirklich ein schwieriger Diskussionsprozess, aber der findet statt. Aber letztlich ist das auch nie so ganz klar. Also es gibt dann eben wahnsinnig viele Einzelfälle, über die dann diskutiert werden muss. Und das kann natürlich auch sehr ermüdend sein. Also das ist ein weiteres Problemfeld, wo wir schon dabei sind, Probleme aufzuzeigen. Das sind dann meistens auch ziemlich schwer lösbare Probleme.
Ja, bleibt die Frage, wie kriegt man da die Köpfe zusammengesteckt? Diskussionen auf Diskussionsseiten erinnern mich teilweise schwer an Diskussionen und Mailinglisten. Die sind sehr mühsam. Vielleicht auch, weil an der Stelle die Software nochmal etwas mehr leisten könnte. Aber auch da habe ich relativ wenig Hoffnung. Dafür gibt es aber natürlich die Real-World-Treffen. Wenn man sich erstmal in die Augen schaut, sieht sowas meistens ganz anders aus. Da gibt es eine Veranstaltung. Gab es zweimal schon die Veranstaltung, richtig? Die Wikimedia, wo warst du auf?
Auf der ersten, in Frankfurt. Die letzte war in Boston, das war dann doch ein bisschen weit. Und die nächste ist in Taipei. Ist mir eigentlich auch ein bisschen zu weit.
Aber da trifft sich so ein bisschen der Wikipedia-Jetset und hält die Köpfe zusammen. Aber es gibt ja auf lokaler Ebene dann auch weitere Aktivitäten.
Genau, da gibt es natürlich dann auch schöne Sachen. Also in Deutschland gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Workshops, die stattfinden. Also jetzt Ende Januar war ja auch ein Workshop in Köln. Das sind da kleinere Veranstaltungen, die dann auch von der Teilnehmerzahl begrenzt sind. Also 30 oder 40 Leute, die sich da befassen. Wer organisiert das? Das wird dann meistens lokal organisiert. Also in Köln zum Beispiel von den lokalen Wikipedianern und zusammen mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Vielleicht mal erwähnen, Chaos Computer Club Köln. Weil ja vorhin du auf eine Diskussion gestoßen bist, wo da immer so ein Antagonismus zwischen dem CCC und der Wikipedia oder Wikimedia konstruiert worden ist, der natürlich gar nicht da ist. Also das ist jetzt gerade in Köln gewesen, dieser Workshop. Und natürlich ist das dann interessant. Und hat natürlich auch selbst in so einer kleinen Gruppe dann die Möglichkeit auch gemeinsam zu diskutieren und dann Dinge auch gleich umzusetzen. Da hat man eine gewisse kritische Masse, die dann auch ein Gewicht hat. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch größere Veranstaltungen. Also im letzten Jahr hat zum ersten Mal in Deutschland die sogenannte Wikipedia Academy stattgefunden, wo man eigentlich eine Verbindung zwischen der traditionellen Bildung, also Bibliotheken, Universitäten und der Wikipedia herstellen wollte. Das hat also in Göttingen an der Staats- und Universitätsbibliothek stattgefunden und an der Universität. Und das war natürlich ziemlich interessant und anregend, klar. Und da kommen natürlich dann mehr Leute. Ich glaube, 160 waren da in Göttingen. Und das wird dieses Jahr nochmal stattfinden. Das soll auch eine Veranstaltung sein, die in Zukunft stattfindet, möglicherweise immer jährlich. Also es gibt in diesem Jahr dann eine Wikipedia Academy in Mainz in Zusammenarbeit mit der Mainzer Akademie der Wissenschaften. Und dann auch wieder versucht wird, traditionelle Formen der Bildung und der Wissenssammlung, also Bibliotheken und Akademien, sind ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt Bildungsinstitutionen, sondern Bildungsinstitutionen im weiteren Sinne, dass sie eben im Wissen sammeln. Eben zusammen mit der Wikipedia und in diesem Fall vertreten dann durch Wikimedia Deutschland. Und das verspreche ich natürlich ziemlich interessant zu werden. Also ich fand die Atmosphäre in Göttingen sehr anregend. Und das war wirklich sehr, sehr interessant. Da hatten wir natürlich auch eine sehr gute Infrastruktur dort, weil natürlich die Bibliothek da auch sehr aufgeschlossen war, uns da zu helfen. Und andererseits wir natürlich das Interesse hatten, mit denen ins Gespräch zu kommen. Und ich denke, das wird in Mainz noch interessanter, weil die Verzahnung dann zwischen den traditionellen Leuten, die sich mit wissen, also Wissenschaftler, Bibliothekare und so weiter, und der Wikipedia da vielleicht noch viel besser ist, weil sie ja bei den Veranstaltungen gemeinsam organisiert wird, auf der einen Seite von der Akademie und von Wikimedia Deutschland. Also ich denke, das ist bestimmt interessant. Und da werden sicherlich auch 150, 200 Leute zusammenkommen. Und ja, das ist natürlich dann eine tolle Möglichkeit, das Virtuelle ins Reale umzusetzen und aus dem Realen wieder ins Virtuelle zurückzuführen.
Dazu gibt es natürlich auch in vielen Städten die Wikipedia-Stammtische, also die festen Treffen der Wikipedianer. Da ist es sinnlos, jetzt irgendeine Liste aufzuzählen. Ich glaube, in jeder größeren Stadt gibt es da irgendwas. Also wer sozusagen Interesse hat, sich einfach mal in den lokalen Dunstkreis ein bisschen reinplumpsen zu lassen, der sollte dort andocken.
Das ist auch zum Teil vernetzt. Also in Bayern zum Beispiel gibt es so Wikipedia Bayern mit Treffen in verschiedenen Städten, Augsburg, München, Nürnberg. Und die reisen nach Rom. Das heißt, ich war einmal beim Treffen in Nürnberg im Sommer im Biergarten. Natürlich sehr schön. Und da kamen dann gleich zwei Autos aus München noch mit dazu. Das sind ja eigentlich alles keine großen Entfernungen. Und da war dann eine richtig große Gruppe. Und das war schon sehr, sehr bunt.
Wikipedia-Tourismus.
Genau, Wikipedia-Tourismus. Genau, in Köln war es ja auch so. Das war richtig Wikipedia-Tourismus. Wir haben da zum Beispiel das Hohe Dach des Domes bestiegen, was man normalerweise auch nicht so kann, mit Sonderführung. Und da habe ich mich wirklich gedacht, das ist ja schlimmer als die japanischen Touristen. Denn natürlich wollten jetzt alle Fotos machen für Commons, weil man jetzt mal Einsichten hatte in den Dombau. Die ganzen Details da, jede kleine Figur, die da drin ist. Das sind ja Abertausende im Dom. Die mussten natürlich jetzt erhalten werden für das freie Wissen. Und es sah wirklich so aus, wie wildgewonnen Japaner, die nur noch rumgeknipst haben. Und die Führerin, die natürlich auch viel erzählen wollte, war so ein bisschen überfordert. Weil sie dann sagt, ach, sie wollen ja nur fotografieren, da brauch ich ja nichts zu erzählen. Dann liest sie aber, nein, sie müssen auch erzählen, weil wir das alles reinschreiben wollen. Wir wollen Text und Bild. Und das war schon so ein bisschen Tourismus.
Ein super Ausflugskonzept, dass man also sich wirklich einen Artikel in der Wikipedia greift, der vielleicht auch schon markiert ist mit, hier müsste mal ein bisschen mehr Butter bei ihr fischen. Dann schleppt man einfach gleich zehn manische Wikipedianer zusammen, stopft die in den Bus, fährt dahin und dann wird das Ding einfach mal übers Wochenende gehackt.
Ja, richtig, gehackt. Das ist eigentlich ein guter Ausdruck. Und das kann man sich ja nun auch alles in der Wikipedia anschauen. Die Ergebnisse des Workshops sind natürlich auch veröffentlicht, auch entsprechend verlinkt und zusammengefasst und mit Kategorie versehen. Also man kann das sehr schnell erschließen, was da geschafft worden ist. Das ist ja immer das Schöne an der Wikipedia oder vielleicht auch das Gefährliche, dass eben alles mitgeschrieben wird. Man kann also genau sehen, dass da z.B. ein Benutzer dann doch nachts über den Chaos Computer Club was geschrieben hat, obwohl er das eigentlich auch hätte woanders machen können.
Schauen wir mal, was über CCC nach diesem Podcast zu lesen ist. Hier wird auch alles mitgeschrieben bzw. alles aufgezeichnet. Und ich denke, wir sind jetzt auch am Ende unseres ausführlichen...
Wir haben doch gerade erst angefangen. Was?
Wir haben erst angefangen?
Da waren noch ein paar Themen auf der Liste.
Na ja, 90 Minuten haben wir jetzt durch. Ich habe keine Themen mehr auf der Liste. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du noch wirklich wichtige Themen... Dann darfst du jetzt sprechen oder musst für immer schweigen. Nein, wir können auch noch eine weitere Fortsetzung der Fortsetzung machen. Aber ich denke, jetzt ist auch erstmal gut. Das war unsere Aufarbeitung des Themas Wikipedia Teil 2. Wer gar keine Ahnung hat, wovon wir reden, kann sich nochmal verweisen auf die unterhaltsame Chaosradio 91. Die war glaube ich die Wikipedia-Sendung. Die war wirklich lustig. Also das war so dermaßen Realtime. Habe ich Radio schon lange nicht mehr erlebt. Aber man soll sich ja nicht selber loben. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine empfehlenswerte 3-Stunden...
Ja, muss ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Genau, muss mal gesagt werden. Chaosradio ist total toll. Das dürft ihr jetzt auch gerne in die Wikipedia schreiben. Ansonsten, wer gar nicht weiß, wovon hier die Rede ist, chaosradio.ccc.de. Das ist das Podcast-Portal vom CCC. Da gibt es Chaosradio. Da gibt es Chaosradio Express. Das, was ihr gerade hört. Es gibt auch eine internationale Version vom Chaosradio Express. Es gibt Chaos TV, wo bunte Tüte Fernsehen bei rauskommt. Lustige Clips, Dokumentationen, schräges Zeug oder sonstige Sachen. Da lässt sich das Programm nicht so hervorhersagen. Und was auch immer wieder von vielen Leuten übersieht, wird der Kanal Dossier-Kaotik, was eine Art audiovisueller Pressespiegel ist. Mittlerweile auch mit Text, also auch Zeitungsartikel, fallen da raus. Mal gucken, wann wir da von dem Copyright-Wahnsinn komplett erschlagen werden. Aber wir müssen das einfach mal dokumentieren. Deswegen muss die Scheiße raus. Und wenn ihr Feedback, Anregungen, Kritik und sonstige Kommentare habt, wie immer, gerne gesehen unter chaosradio.ac.c.cde. Lesen wir eure Mail gerne und wir beantworten sie auch.
Wir brauchen aber auch einen Blog. Also irgendwie finde ich das jetzt nicht so schön, dass man kein richtiges Feedback mit Kommentaren und so.
Das finde ich auch nicht und ich arbeite dran. Okay. Es kommt.
Dann freuen wir uns.
Dann haben wir uns jetzt gefreut. Und können wir nur noch Tschüss sagen. Danke, Maha, für die ausführliche Eräuterung.
Ja, bitte.
Und ich sage Tschüss an alle Hörer. Bis zum nächsten Mal bei Chaosradio Express.
Ciao.